you can take two ingredients that sound
like they would be completely disgusting
together and once they meet they're
actually pretty wonderful so my little
brother and I would have these
competitions while we were all latchkey
home alone this was before the Internet
instead of watching other people do
stupid stuff you actually had to do
stupid stuff yourself it's got the sweet
yellow sponge cake with cream filling
the all-beef dog you get a horseradish
on there just give a little fire some
hot sauce top it up some nice
breadcrumbs just some you know
marshmallow fluff ooh oh it looks good
this looks like cartoon food I'll
endorse this the more acute more taste
like vomit the more you chew it gets
worse I really would do that I would eat
it if I were like under the influence of
something late at night and I mean the
backseat and I was basically just like
lazy and probably fighting with my
sister and I didn't want to hold
everything so I just put them all
together on the pizza and that became my
frankenfood it smells like a diaper pail
before there's diapers in it's okay hope
you feel like you're coaching me through
this one doesn't go nothing goes no no
they're so computer I'm not hating it I
should hate this during Passover Seder
among other things we would have gefilte
fish for those who don't know it's a
meat loaf of fish it's terrible the only
way to get it down was for my parents to
mix it with mac and cheese which was my
favorite thing of all time as a kid and
if this was very cruel of them because
in effect they brainwashed me taste is
is not the strongest
Oh oh my god fills the fish is
disgusting oh my god it's strikes for
pee and fish and feces and all the bad
things I started experimenting with a
lot of breakfast food eventually I kind
of came up with cookies and cream
french toast souffle which is the edible
version of my childhood favorite it's
like french toast with chocolate the
gleason chocolate cookies yeah this is
really good I'm good with this should
just be a thing yeah you know if you
didn't have some guy that decided to put
meat into bread
there'd be no sandwich out there so you
you have to kind of go through life a
little bit of a frankenfood mentality
otherwise everything you eat is just
gonna suck